well hello you guys hey how you doing so
I feel like I'm witnessing a little
bromance going on
it's nothing little about it bro magic
now yeah it's bro magical magic because
this films about magic yeah we're having
a Imagi cough that's right there you go
yeah that's right
what magic spell do you wish you had in
real life we said this earlier I would
like the power to recycle all the
plastic in the world and save the oceans
because I like I love the oceans and
scuba diving is one of my favorite
things to do in our careers one of the
very few downsides is the idea of
privacy and going places where people
can't see you and when you're under the
water and there's manta rays and stuff
people are more interested in the manta
rays than they are with you so one of my
favorite things to do in life is to go
scuba diving because all of a sudden
you're just a person under the water and
I'm so sad to see how we are affecting
our oceans and if I could do something
and get rid of all the plastic that
would be my my spell 100% I think
pollutions in the waters is is it is a
would be that'd be awesome to be able to
affect that I'm a fisherman I love being
out in the water I love to scuba dive
and snorkel as well yeah and you see a
lot of that the reefs dying US of A sad
it's it's unfortunate that's like the
last bastion that's it seems like the
last untouched part of the earth yeah
you go underwater to scuba dive and all
of us and you see all these fish and you
think well that's probably what the
prairies were at one point before they
were covered in houses and Rose doesn't
like that so yeah that'd be nice
I might also like to be able to just
like snap my fingers and make someone
else crap their pants if I could make
some a crappy coffee it's not my fingers
I love that this film made me laugh you
guys are fantastic in it but crying like
a child
did you guys have an emotional
connection to this story and wanting to
be a part of it I know that you guys
have siblings but what made you want to
sign on
oh I have such a strong relationship
with my dad that I recognized the
importance of telling this story because
some people have been unfortunate like
my granddad for example lost his dad
when he was 18 months old so I
recognized the important importance of
telling this story because I've been so
privileged and lucky that my dad has
been around and been able to raise us in
the way that he has so I just felt an
obligation and responsibility to tell
this story in a very truthful way and I
think a lot of my relationships with my
family and my dad in particular kind of
poured into this film which I think is
why it makes it so emotional yeah our
director Dan Scanlon who pitched this
idea to me at Pixar and it's rooted so
much in a real story of his life hidden
and his own brother having lost their
father in the quest to discover more
about him and so this story when he
pitched me that idea it was very
emotional I matheran and I were both of
it Pixar up in Northern California and
and we were both moved to tears just
hearing the pitch yeah and it was in
that moment that I wanted to do anything
I could to have to help Dan tell his
story and for me it also resonates that
I have a I'm a I'm a younger brother but
my brother and I and I've got a sister
as well you know we lost our father now
it's been I think it was like five or
six years ago and so for that it really
resonated but to me mostly it was just
the empathy I felt for Dan in his
situation and wanting to be able to be a
part of him telling this magnificent
original story yeah thank you